[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rocket League was a phenomenon when it
debuted in 2015 and two years later it
shows no signs of slowing down the
unorthodox sports game is a mix of
soccer and vehicular acrobatics that's
immediately engaging but a high skill
ceiling ensures that you can put
hundreds of hours into rocket League and
continue to improve your control of her
car and ball lake in our original review
editor miguel concepción said the
promising concept of combining two
wonderful things cars and soccer is
equally magnificent in execution it's
unique it's complex and now that it's on
switch it's wonderfully portable rocket
league makes the leap to handheld
courtesy of developer panic button the
same team responsible for the
respectable switchport of doom and
similar to that conversion rocket
leagues visuals have been somewhat
stripped down to maintain a steady frame
rate under switches hardware limitations
the impact of the downgraded visuals can
be seen in the games jagged edges and
fluctuating texture resolutions but
unlike a game that relies on a world to
set the stage for characters and
narrative events rocket leagues switch
scars are easily overlooked
the only time when they may interfere is
when playing handheld where jagged
models make it occasionally difficult to
differentiate between objects in the
foreground and background on switches
small display this thankfully is rarely
an issue when you're focused on a
handful of other drivers and protecting
your goal from a fast-moving ball
jaggies are the least of your concerns
and when subconsciously calculating your
trajectory as you ramp up onto a wall
and blast your Rockets for a last-minute
boost to slam a ball into the back of a
goal from midair you probably aren't
focused on a blurry texture here or
there
block a league on switch isn't always a
pretty game but that doesn't stop it
from being every bit as exciting and
competitive as it is on other platforms
as someone who's spent upwards of 200
hours with other versions of rocket
League I was pleased to find that
jumping into matches on switch was just
as easy as before in terms of both
matchmaking and controlling my car in
the field thanks in part to the
rock-solid frame rate the decreased
visual fidelity stood out in fleeting
moments but so too did the Mario and
Metroid cars that I unlocked
he's a Nintendo exclusive rise and their
series appropriate sound effects or
small touches that make the switch
version feel slightly more special than
it otherwise would have this also goes
for the local split-screen play relative
to the constraints of playing on a small
screen it works as well as you'd hope to
say nothing of the surprising
effectiveness of controlling your car
with a mere single joique on it's small
but it gets the job done
makes to Microsoft's cooperation and
developers psionics is handy work switch
players can engage in cross network play
with a wide majority of rocket leagues
existing community as evidence during
our pre-launch tests this system works
without a hitch and matches are readily
available the one notable caveat when it
comes to playing online with others is
that creating custom messages mid-match
is less convenient than usual this is
because toggling chat brings up a window
that takes up the entire screen leaving
you without the usual live feed that
runs in the background in other versions
of the game you do have the option of
connecting a USB keyboard if you want to
type out messages while your switch is
docked which can help speed up the
process save for its presentation rocket
League on switches every bit the game it
is elsewhere and when you factor in its
newfound portability it's also the most
versatile that alone makes it attractive
to regular rocket League competitors for
people new to the game they have a lot
to look forward to regardless as rocket
League is one of the most fascinating
sports games in memory never mind if you
don't like soccer or could care less
about the games growing eSports
community rocket league is a unique game
that redefines the concepts of what a
sports game can be and psionics
continues to support it with new content
on a regular basis it's been around for
a while but now that rocket League is on
switch there's no better time to give it
a shot
[Music]